Hopefully these last two examples illustrated the concept of type I and type II
errors. But now to wrap up this lesson, let's apply type I and type II errors
to the question of whether or not a musical lesson will increase engagement.
Remember that our population parameter was 7.47 and this is from the actual
responses from the survey that I sent out. And the actual population standard
deviation was 2.41. Our new hypothesis, then, will be that the new population
mean after the intervention will not have a significant change from this
population parameter. In other words, there won't be a treatment effect. And
the alternative hypothesis is that there is a treatment effect. So the two
parameters will be significantly different. Now let's say that we have a sample
of size 30, and the mean engagement is 8.3, however the true engagement of the
population if we were to implement this musical lesson, will be 7.8. Now in
real life we don't know what muse sub song will be but let's pretend we do. If
this happens, then which of these four quadrants represents the results of our
hypothesis test? This is a pretty tough question and it requires you to
remember what we did before and then really understand Type I and Type II
errors. Give it your best shot. Let's say our alpha level is 0.05 and this is
for a two-tailed test.